avant de donner la parole à monsieur
adnot vous saluer monsieur le premier
ministre c'est la première fois vous
êtes ici au bord du gouvernement avec le
ministre en charge des relations avec le
parlement
je vois quatre collègues ministre d'état
ministre secrétaire d'état qui sont
autour du beau et bien sûr je
l'accueille des autres ministres avec
plaisir et bonheur cet après midi au
sénat avant que nous abordions l'ordre
du jour je vais donner la parole à au
président philippe adnot
merci monsieur le président il s'agit
d'une rectification de vote pour le
scrutin numéro 104 monsieur navarro a
été considéré comme n'ayant pas pris
part au vote et ils souhaitaient faire
savoir que ils souhaitaient voter pour
tes donc donné de cette mise au point
qui sera publié au journal officiel et
figurera dans l'analyse politique du
scrutin
monsieur anoh l'ordre du jour appelle
donc une déclaration du gouvernement
suivie d'un débat
en application de l'article 50-1 de la
constitution et la parole et donc à
monsieur edouard philippe premier
ministre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le premier ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs hier monsieur le
ministre d'état ministre de l'intérieur
vous a comme le veut la coutume donné
lecture de la déclaration de politique
générale aux le mans au lendemain du
vote de la confiance par l'assemblée
nationale
je ne pouvais qu'être devant vous
aujourd'hui dans cet hémicycle pour
m'adresser directement à vous n'ayant
pas eu le privilège de siéger parmi vous
je n'ai pas le plaisir de tous vous
connaître sans doute
certes certes des visages sur ses bancs
nous sont familiers et même amicaux
certains ont jalonné mon parcours
d'autres m'ont aidé à le construire mais
je ne parle pas seulement de ses grandes
figures de notre histoire politique
victor schoelcher victor hugo georges
clemenceau ou permettez moi de le citer
le havrais rené coty dont les voix et
les intelligences ont fait vibrer ses
muses
j'ai par ailleurs l'honneur de compter
dans mon gouvernement des membres et
anciens membres de votre assemblée
le sénat se confond avec la république
il en est un pôle d'équilibré
il est à la fois en prise directe avec
le quotidien de millions de français et
à l'écart d'une certaine fébrilité
politique
cette sérénité démocratique est une
chance hier dans mon discours j'ai
commencé par rendre hommage à des
nouveaux députés qui par leur parcours
ont remodelé le visage d'une partie de
la représentation nationale
je sais que comme vous ils auront à
coeur de nouer un dialogue fructueux
pour faire avancer le travail
parlementaire et pour faire réussir la
france si je les mentionne de nouveau
aujourd'hui c'est que je m'adresse à une
assemblée qui durant 21 ans a confié sa
destinée aux petits fils d'un esclave
elle l'a fait à une époque où les
préjugés et est encore plus rude est
encore plus injuste
que de nos jours vos prédécesseurs n'ont
pas choisi gaston monnerville pour ses
origines mais pour cette talent des
talents qui n'auraient pas pu s'épanouir
si la république ne les avait pas
reconnu et pas encourager ces deux sets
république de cette france de l'égalité
des chances que je veux parler
aujourd'hui une france qui dans les
moments les plus difficiles de son
histoire a toujours été capable
détonnant sursaut cette france s'est
exprimé durant la campagne
présidentielle
elle a exprimé sa colère mais elle a
aussi exprimé son optimisme et sa
volonté de rassemblement
avant-hier devant le parlement réuni en
congrès le président de la république
nous a montré le cap
il est clair il sera tenu les français
ont d'ailleurs dans un souci de
cohérence donner au président et au
gouvernement une majorité claire et
incontestable au sein de l'assemblée
nationale
je ne prends pas mesdames et messieurs
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire je le
redis je ne prends pas cette majorité
pour un blanc seing il est évident comme
toutes les majorités qu'elle implique
bien plus de devoirs que de droits
et parmi ses devoirs figure évidemment
la nécessité de respecter les
institutions démocratiques
j'y veillerai mais la france doit
avancer dans notre cher et vieux pays il
existe une envie une énergie un espoir
qui transcende les courants politiques
le gouvernement veut s'appuyer sur cette
envie est sûre cette énergie pour que la
france retrouve confiance
j'ai eu l'occasion de le décliner hier
confiance dans l'action publique
confiance dans la justice confiance dans
la sécurité sociale et confiance dans la
cohésion territoriale
je veux m'appuyer sur cette énergie pour
que collectivement nous fassions preuve
de courage devant les menaces
terroristes et tout ce qui peut menacer
la sécurité des français devant le défi
migratoire pour être fidèle à la fois
nos idéaux et à nos responsabilités pour
préparer l'avenir de nos enfants aussi
en refondant l'école
pour rénover notre modèle social il en a
besoin pour réduire la dette et la
dépense publique c'est indispensable
je m'appuie sur cette énergie pour que
la france redevienne conquérante pour
qu'elle redevienne une terre d'accueil
des compétences des entreprises d
investissement d intelligence pour
qu'elle restaure la puissance de son
agriculture qu'elle saisisse la chance
de la transition écologique et qu'elle
assume pleinement sa vocation européenne
et internationale
hier j'ai indiqué la feuille de route du
gouvernement
son calendrier sa méthode je veux les
résumer en quelques mots clés la
collégialité la sincérité la recherche
permanente de l'efficacité et non de la
popularité
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire et monsieur
le ministre d'état a eu l'occasion de
dire lui aussi hier combien je pensais
que l'exercice du pouvoir était avant
tout un exercice de vérité il n'est pas
impossible
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs que
durant trop longtemps notre pays ait
pris la mauvaise habitude de s'arranger
un peu avec la vérité la cour des
comptes avec ces mots nous en a donné
une triste illustration
j'y vois une des causes des crises de la
confiance qui a secoué notre pays
la vérité elle n'est pas bâtie dans
l'antre des ministères et au sein des
cabinets ministériels
elle se construit elle se constate
parfois elle se construit aussi dans le
respect dans le dialogue avec les
partenaires sociaux avec les acteurs
économiques avec le monde associatif
c'est pourquoi nous avons voulu avec le
président de la république prendre sur
toute une série de sujets le temps de la
concertation le temps de la discussion
du dialogue avec les parties prenantes
sur ceux des sujets qui structurent
l'avenir du pays c'est le sens des états
généraux de l'alimentation et de
l'agriculture
c'est le sens des assises de l'outre-mer
des états généraux des comptes de la
nation et j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure
de la conférence des territoires l'idée
de discuter
à l'extérieur des assemblées pour
délibérer ensuite à l'intérieur des
assemblées sur les actes législatifs qui
doivent mettre en oeuvre un certain
nombre de principes qui ont pu être
discutée n'est pas une méthode nouvelle
elle a fait ses preuves
beaucoup d'entre vous la connaissez pour
l'avoir pratiqué soit ici soit dans
l'action publique locale
elle est efficace pour produire les
normes et définir les règles qui seront
acceptés de tous je veux donc associer
des phases de discussion à l'extérieur
des assemblées à des phases de
délibération intense à l'intérieur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
je ne veux pas vous infliger une seconde
lecture de la déclaration de politique
générale
ce serait mal venu
je ne veux pas non plus vous infligez de
lecture abrégé et commentez vous n'en
avez pas besoin
non je veux profiter de ma présence ici
pour aborder deux sujets qui vous
tiennent à coeur
deux sujets sur lequel j'ai des choses à
dire et j'en suis sûr des choses à
apprendre de fou le premier sujet est
institutionnel je crois au bicamérisme
je mesure le rôle du sénat dans le bon
fonctionnement de notre démocratie
c'est un ancien député qui vous le dit
je connais la qualité de vos débats je
connais aussi la qualité des textes qui
sortent du sénat la qualité du travail
en commission qui s' y conduit je crois
au bicamérisme et j'y tiens
aucune démocratie ne fonctionne avec une
seule chambre
[Applaudissements]
les mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
j'y ai toujours cru mais j'y crois plus
encore aujourd'hui
pas simplement parce que je vous parle
ce qui est déjà considérable mais parce
que le bicamérisme prend plus encore son
sens aujourd'hui qu'hier
d'un côté nous avons une assemblée
nationale profondément renouvelée et ce
renouvellement était nécessaire il était
voulue par les français il a été
démocratique claire il est une chance
pour notre pays mais de l'autre nous
avons un sénat où siègent des élus élus
par des élus des élus qui connaissent
mieux que quiconque la réalité des
territoires de la république
des élus qui incarne une expérience des
territoires et du processus législatif
le sénat depuis longtemps à renoncer aux
clivages artificiels
on y pratique le sens du consensus et du
compromis
on y aime la discussion le dialogue on
s'était marié les bonnes volontés le
sénat de ce point de vue a probablement
largement anticipé la logique que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui et cette
expérience nous en aurons besoin pour
préparer les réformes constitutionnelles
dont le président a dessiné les contours
avant-hier devant le parlement réuni en
congrès réduction d'un tiers du nombre
de parlementaires limitation à trois du
nombre de mandats successifs suppression
de la cour de justice de la république
refonte du conseil économique social et
environnemental évolution du travail
parlementaire pour le rendre plus
efficace et quand cela est nécessaire
plus rapide ces réformes seront d'une
ampleur dont je ne sais si elle est
inédite
mais qui est à l'évidence considérable
le sénat sous l'impulsion de son
président gérard larcher a pris les
devants le 11 mars 2015 à votre
conférence des présidents a adopté 46
mesures qui ont conduit à une
modification du règlement le 13 mai 2015
et qui ont en particulier valoriser le
travail en commission cette expérience
vous aurez l'occasion de la faire valoir
par l'intermédiaire de votre président
dans le cadre de la réflexion qui
s'engage avec le président de
l'assemblée nationale le ministre d'état
ministre de l'intérieur et la garde des
sceaux
j'y serai pour ma part très attentif
elle nous montre une chose importante
est que même des législateurs doivent
avoir en tête et dont je sais que vous
l'avez en tête c'est que tout ne passe
pas par la norme constitutionnelle lui
même par la loi et que la constitution
identique les méthodes de travail
peuvent être différentes et qu'il faut
s'inspirer pour régler les problèmes non
pas simplement des modifications de
normes mais des usages qui fonctionne
bien et des règles décidées dans les
assemblées qui fonctionne bien le second
sujet que je voulais aborder avec vous
concerne l'organisation territoriale de
notre pays je les dis hier devant
l'assemblée nationale
les jardins à la française ont leur
charme mais nous pouvons ensemble
reconnaître qu'il se prête assez peu
foisonnement d'initiatives dont le pays
a besoin et auxquels les collectivités
elles-mêmes sont prêtes
ce que nous voulons c'est que les
collectivités locales soient fortes et
libres libres de s'organiser en
développant des communes nouvelles ou
des regroupements département à
condition bien sûr que ces fusions ne
soient pas contraires à l'intérêt
général
libre d'exercer de nouvelles compétences
libre aussi de mieux se les répartir
par exemple par le mandat de délégations
libre d'expérimenter non seulement de
nouvelles organisations de nouvelles
compétences mais aussi de nouvelles
règles d'exercice des compétences dans
le cadre d'un élargissement du pouvoir
réglementaire local liberté et confiance
tels sont les deux fondements de la
décentralisation d'aujourd'hui une
décentralisation qui ne se décrète plus
depuis paris mais qui s'expérimente qui
ce test et qui s'adapte je ne crois pas
qu'il nous faille décider pour les
autres cela peut arriver mais je pense
qu'il faut dans toute la mesure du
possible un site et inciter les
territoires adaptées localement leur
organisation pour tendre partout où cela
sera possible vers deux niveaux
d'administration locale en dessous du
niveau régional le même schéma
n'existera pas partout mais essayons de
susciter chez les collectivités chez
leurs élus les discussions qui nous
permettrait le cas échéant à tel endroit
de privilégier tel ou tel interlocuteur
à tel endroit et librement de
privilégier tel ou tel autre
organisation
cette simplification répond à une
exigence de bonne gestion elle répond
aussi à une exigence de lisibilité
l'empilement actuelle n'est pas toujours
compris de nos concitoyens bien
évidemment cette liberté s'accompagnera
de solidarité une solidarité qui
s'exprime d'abord au niveau de l'état
par la création d'un ministère de la
cohésion des territoires dont le
titulaire est issu de vos rangs cette
solidarité elle s'exprimera aussi par de
grands chantiers sectorielle dans le
domaine de la santé
j'ai demandé à la ministre de préparer
pour le mois de septembre un plan de
lutte contre les déserts médicaux
je sais que le sénat a beaucoup
travaillé sur le sujet sur ce sujet est
crucial pour l'égalité entre nos
territoires
ce plan sera construit dans le dialogue
avec les élus locaux et les
professionnels de santé pour trouver des
solutions adaptées à chacun des
territoires
ce sera long
ce sera long car à l'évidence il n'y a
pas simplement un problème de
répartition immédiate sur le territoire
et nous ne pouvons pas répartir
immédiatement brutalement depuis paris
l'ensemble de ceux qui concourent au
métier de santé sur le territoire mais
nous pouvons faire en sorte nous
semble-t-il par une meilleure
organisation par de meilleures relations
avec ceux qui défendent et porte les
intérêts de l'ensemble des professions
médicales
nous pouvons faire en sorte d'améliorer
cette répartition est de créer des
mécanismes incitatifs pour que au fur et
à mesure de notre action cette question
terrible pour nos concitoyens de déserts
médicaux qui ne sont pas réduits à
quelques territoires mais qui deviennent
à certains égards presque la norme
puisse être résolu dans les meilleures
conditions
dans le domaine de la mobilité
dès la rentrée se tiendront des assises
de la mobilité
elles associeront les usagers des
opérateurs les collectivités
territoriales et les associations
engagées dans ces domaines
leur but est double bâtir une stratégie
adaptée aux besoins des territoires
permettant de mieux utiliser les
infrastructures existantes en
bénéficiant des possibilités par exemple
offertes par le numérique
construire une programmation financière
soutenable soutenable qui fera porter
l'effort n'ont pris sur les grandes
infrastructures
mais sur l'entretien et la rénovation
des réseaux actuels pas rénovation et
l'entretien des réseaux actuels qui de
toute évidence ne sont pas satisfaisants
autre chantier sectorielle sur lequel le
sénat est devenu expert le numérique
comme je me suis engagé hier je souhaite
un accès garanti pour tous et partout en
france au très haut débit au plus tard
en 2022
mais là encore là encore gardons-nous de
raisonner seulement en terme
d'infrastructures
dans son service service à l'usager
services aux collectivités
cette politique d'accès au numérique
nous permettra de déployer de nouveaux
projets je pense notamment aux comptes
citoyens en ligne qui pourraient devenir
demain l'interface de base la norme
entre les administrations et le citoyen
dernier chantier la revitalisation des
petites villes et des bourgs centres
trop longtemps négligé dans les
politiques publiques qui mérite à la
fois une attention particulière et une
stratégie propre à chaque territoire
la situation n'est pas la même en alsace
que dans le massif central ou en
outre-mer
ces chantiers poursuivent un objectif
combler le fossé qui se creuse entre
deux france que certains voudraient
opposer entre de france qui se vivent
parfois comme entrant en opposition mais
entre de france qui ne peuvent pas
réussir l'une sans l'autre
j'entends par là évidemment la france
des métropoles mondialisé et celles
dites périphériques
c'est tout l'objet de la conférence
nationale des territoires que le
président de la république a souhaité
constituer et dont la première réunion
se tiendra mi juillet si vous en êtes
d'accord
elle pourrait justement se tenir au
sénat et monsieur le président du sénat
[Applaudissements]
pourrait y tenir le rôle éminent qui lui
revient vous serez évidemment
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
représentés de façon permanente au sein
de cette instance par ceux de votre
assemblée
parce que votre assemblée aura des idées
un dernier mot peut-être sur les aspects
financiers gelé d'hier la situation de
nos finances publiques est plus que
préoccupante elle est grave et nous
devons tous contribuer à l'effort de
redressement
je sais que les collectivités
territoriales y ont déjà contribué
je le sais partout y compris dans les
grands ports
je ne sous estime pas loin de là les
conséquences de ces efforts je crois la
responsabilité des élus locaux comme je
crois à leur sens des réalités
ils gèrent des budgets et il les gère
parfois dans des conditions difficiles
ils sont amenés à faire des choix à
revoir des priorités à assumer des
priorités je sais aussi que faire avec
moins peut parfois pas toujours conduire
à faire mieux c'est à dire proposer des
services plus simples plus agile et plus
efficace nous ouvrirons le dialogue avec
les élus pour bâtir une trajectoire
commune de maîtrise de la dépense
publique
nous engagerons également la réforme de
la taxe d'habitation qui doit d'ici la
fin du quinquennat
d'ici la fin du quinquennat ça ne veut
pas dire que on attend la fin du
quinquennat pour faire en sorte que la
réforme soit entière
ça veut dire qu'on commence pendant le
quinquennat et qu'à la fin du
quinquennat
c'est terminé je le dis parce que
peut-être certains hier aurait pu se
méprendre sur la portée de mes propos
c'est tout cas le sentiment que j'ai eu
je sais cette réforme
attendu par les contribuables mais
redoutée par les élus parlons-en
parlons-en avec le sénat avec le comité
des finances locales pour réformer cet
impôt dont on ne peut pas dire qu'il
soit le plus juste sans porter atteinte
à l'autonomie financière des
collectivités territoriales ce sujet
fiscal comme celui de la dépense
publique seront évidemment au coeur de
la prochaine conférence nationale des
territoires au delà de la taxe
d'habitation
je crois pouvoir dire ici que les élus
locaux que les sénateurs encore plus que
les élus locaux ont parfaitement
conscience du caractère globalement
insatisfaisant de la fiscalité locale
souvent incompréhensibles largement
illisible et pardon pour ce mot mais
globalement inefficace et dans les faits
souvent corriger pour faire face aux
problèmes du moment
si bien que les deux venus à bien des
égards un peu incohérente
je ne suis pas venu mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs vous annoncer le
grand soir de la fiscalité locale ou la
grande réforme qui sortirait toute armée
du crâne d'un spécialiste que je ne
prétends pas être mais là encore dans
nos échanges dans nos travaux collectifs
nous pouvons je crois partager ce
constat et nous pouvons peut-être lancer
ses réflexions au long cours qui parce
qu'elles sont bien travaillé notamment
par le sénat finissent par prospérer et
par déboucher sur de bonnes réformes
il existe des exemples et essayer de
faire en sorte que le moment venu une
fois que la totalité des question a été
posée débattues discutées
peut-être dans longtemps nous ayons
globalement un système
de finances locales et de fiscalité
locale plus satisfaisant que celui qui
prévaut aujourd'hui monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je connais comme vous les limites du
politique mais je ne crois pas son
impuissance
la volonté politique peut faire
je les ai vus comme beaucoup d'entre
vous en exerçant mon mandat de maire et
nous sommes tous frappés quel que soit
l'endroit où nous nous asseyons sur les
bancs des assemblées
nous sommes tous frappé par le contraste
saisissant qui prévaut entre le constat
qu'on fait souvent de notre pays qui
seraient bloqués comme arrêter et
l'incroyable transformation d'un certain
nombre de nos territoires qui par
l'action résolue d'élus locaux par la
cohérence de l'action qui est conduite
par la vision même qui est définie par
l'acceptation par les citoyens de ces
transformations ont connu des évolutions
majeures et bénéfiques se promener dans
les territoires français c'est
évidemment pardon pour l'expression se
promener lé mais enfin vous voyez
parcourir merci monsieur le sénateur
parcourir la france c'est constater la
difficulté d'un certain nombre de
territoires mais c'est aussi constaté
partout en france l'incroyable succès
des politiques publiques locales
conduites par des élus locaux
et bien cela veut dire que la politique
tout cela veut dire que lorsque la
volonté forte lorsque la majorité est
stable lorsque le dialogue est réel
lorsque la cohérence guident l'action on
peut réussir cette méthode de travail le
gouvernement la propose aux législateurs
que vous êtes en y ajoutant bien entendu
le respect et l'exigence de vérité
je vous propose donc de vrais ensemble
dans cet esprit
sinon de consensus mais le débat qui
n'interdit la franchise ni la
contradiction bien entendu mais qui
pourrait nous permettre qu'à la fin de
ce quinquennat nous ayons réussi les
réformes que les français et les
territoires attendre je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]